77ème assemblée générale des Nations
unies s'ouvrent aujourd'hui à New York
en présence de 150 chefs d'états de
gouvernement un campus vide sans
étudiant et sans cours voilà quoi
devrait ressembler l'Université de
Strasbourg deux semaines l'hiver
prochain la direction a décidé de fermer
les bâtiments pour faire baisser la
facture de chauffage ce poste a tout de
ceux des influenceurs mais à bien été
publié par le CROUS de Strasbourg un jeu
concours pour gagner un ou deux mois
deux repas gratuits au restaurant
universitaire ça ne passe pas autre
monde est au plus mal
les clivages s'accentuent les inégalités
se creusent concrètement les vacances de
Noël seraient prolongées d'une semaine
sans aucun cours et en février une
semaine serait en distancielle à la
maison face au CROUS et le service
d'insertion de l'université ont annulé
le concours ce matin l'unique but de ce
jeu était de faire connaître au plus
grand nombre les contes de ces deux
organismes en aucune façon le CROUS de
Strasbourg n'a souhaité instrumentaliser
la précarité étudiante à seulement 5 km
des côtes camarguaises 5 mètres de long
pour un poids de plus d'une tonne pour
se spécialiste la vidéo ne laisse pas de
place au doute il s'agit bien d'un grand
requin blanc c'est une députée de chez
vous qui a fait un communiqué pour dire
qu'elle n'appréciait pas cette prise de
position nous avons un
un communiqué de presse qui a été fait
par la coordination des espaces de la
France insoumise
dans lequel nous nous retrouvons toutes
et tous C'est pas ma question c'est sur
le tweet de Jean-Luc Mélenchon le
fondateur en 2018 l'espèce était
considérée comme étant à 98% et bonne
nouvelle il s'agit d'une femelle au
ventre arrondi l'expression politique
qui a eu lieu ce week-end notamment
d'Adrien cadenas et a révélé des une
situation grave que nous prenons que
nous avons pris très au sérieux d'où le
communiqué de presse de la coordination
des espaces du mouvement la conférence
de presse à laquelle on vient d'assister
là de la part de la France insoumise et
tout à fait lunaire on devrait leur
donner on devrait leur délivrer une
médaille d'or d'aviron parce que il rame
ils ont toujours les mots pour dire non
non mais là c'est du retrait les autres
c'est la dignité le courage d'Adrien
donc quand il s'agit de ceux qui ne sont
pas d'extrême gauche là la potence
l'aurait garantie évidemment extrêmement
choquant d'avoir quelqu'un qui banalise
des violences intrafamiliales enfin
voilà c'est pas une outrance près on va
dire
quand monsieur Caron dit dans un tweet
BFM TV chaîne française de propagande
israélienne du milliardaire israélien
dry alors il a enlevé le tweet après
enfin il a tweeté ça j'entends Sandrine
Rousseau hier par exemple expliquer que
la victime enfin qu'elle a reçu en tout
cas l'ex-compagne de Julien Bailly
qu'elle explique que cette femme a fait
une tentative de suicide je ne sais pas
si cette femme a envie que toute la
France soit au courant qu'elle a fait
une tentative de suicide cette femme
elle était dans un état vraiment très
très déprimé voire enfin vraiment très
mal très très mal d'ailleurs elle a fait
cette tentative de suicide quelques
semaines après tellement elle allait
elle allait mal et il avait révélé
lui-même cette affaire qui n'est pas
visée par la justice il avait alors
affirmé qu'elle ne constituait en rien
des violences mais qu'il s'agissait
d'une histoire qui se terminait dans la
souffrance et le problème a-t-elle lancé
micro coupé c'est qu'il n'y a rien de
pénal rien de pénalement répréhensible
dans cette histoire a-t-elle dit
autrement dit le chef des Verts n'aurait
que mais dans l'esprit de Sandrine
Rousseau son comportement conjugal
mérite la honte et l'eau propre du
déballage de sa vie privée ce qu'elle a
fait hier soir quand même un doute sur
ce qui s'est passé hier soir une
Sandrine Rousseau qui dit bah voilà
Julien Bayou comme ça mais ça c'est la
méthode Rousseau on est quand même dans
une situation on a un peu d'arroser ce
qui donne des leçons de morale et bien
se retrouve sous le sous le feu des
projecteurs Thomas porte ancien du Parti
communiste aujourd'hui député la France
insoumise de la troisième
circonscription de Seine-Saint-Denis qui
d'après mes confrères de Mediapart
aurait été lui aussi signalé comme ayant
un comportement vis-à-vis des femmes qui
n'étaient pas acceptables Florent
calques s'étaient échoué hier sur une
plage de poevin à pu repartir en mer
dans la nuit une opération rendue
possible par des pompiers et des
bénévoles j'ai entendu que chez nous il
y avait eu des cas de de
d'agression de la en direction de de
militantes du Parti communiste vous
l'avez entendu là où la vie a entendu à
l'époque j'ai entendu dans les dans
l'article de Mediapart d'accord oui vous
n'aviez pas entendu parler à l'époque
vous n'aviez pas de soupçons de doute ou
de témoignages